la batalla jurídica apenas empieza en
Estados Unidos la corte de apelaciones
del quinto circuito concede Nueva
Orleans suspendió la orden del juez del
distrito amarillo en Texas Matthew cax
Maverick que prohibía el uso de la
píldora abortiva mifepristona un
medicamento ampliamente utilizado y que
cuenta con el visto bueno de la agencia
de medicamentos estadounidense fda hace
más de 20 años sin embargo la corte
admitió dos peticiones del juez nominado
al cargo por Donald Trump el uso de la
píldora quedaría sujeto a restricciones
no podrá administrarse sin visitar a un
médico el envío por correo del
medicamento no está autorizado y su uso
se limitará las primeras siete semanas
de gestación frente a las 10 permitidas
anteriormente el departamento de
Justicia anunció una apelación ante la
Corte Suprema
buscaremos una intervención de urgencia
del tribunal supremo para defender el
juicio científico de la fda y proteger
el acceso de los estadounidenses a un
servicio seguro y efectivo el gobierno
biden apoya abiertamente el uso de la
píldora abortiva pero ante todo se opone
a que una decisión judicial pueda pasar
por encima del consenso científico y
anular decisiones médicas Los
profesionales de la salud se están
preparando por si el fármaco deja de
estar disponible
si se elimina como opción seguimos
teniendo opciones para el aborto con
medicamentos pero la otra opción que
utilizamos habitualmente Es un régimen
solo con misoprostol lo que supondría
más efectos secundarios y algo menos de
eficacia
la batalla por el aborto legal en
Estados Unidos se encendió después de
que la Corte Suprema derogar el
histórico fallo de sus wait ahora una
nueva decisión queda en manos del máximo
tribunal donde la mayoría conservadora
se mantiene